[موسيقى
] عرض لأحدث أسلحة كوريا الشمالية
وأكثرها طموحًا خلفية
لكيم جونغ أون للاحتفال بالذكرى الـ 76
لحزب العمال
ولإثارة غضب الديكتاتور على الولايات المتحدة معلناً أنه يحتاج إلى هذه
الأسلحة للدفاع عن بلاده
ضد العدو.  نحن التي يقول إنها تسبب
عدم الاستقرار في شبه الجزيرة الكورية ،
لكن الأسلحة والطريقة التي تم
تقديمها بها هي التي أثارت قلق المحللين
الليلة ، لم نر شيئًا
كهذا من قبل ، وفي الواقع عندما وضع كل
صواريخه معًا بدا الأمر مثل
سميثسونيان  لقد توصل إلى
صالة
العرض هذه تقريبًا مثل بائع سيارات يوضح
ما
هو موجود في الكثير من القوة الفتاكة بما في ذلك
ما تدعي كوريا الشمالية أنه صاروخ تفوق سرعة الصوت
برأس حربي شراعي قابل للفصل
تم اختباره لأول مرة الشهر الماضي سلاحًا
يقول الخبراء إنه من الصعب للغاية
إسقاط صاروخ كروز جديد يطير على
ارتفاع منخفض على الأرض تم اختباره لأول مرة
الشهر الماضي أيضًا معروضًا ما
يعتقد المحللون أنه  يعد hwasong-16
أحد أكبر الصواريخ الباليستية العابرة للقارات في العالم والتي من
المحتمل أن تكون قادرة على حمل
رؤوس حربية متعددة تم عرضها في المسيرات الأخيرة ولكن لا
يُعتقد أنه تم اختبارها ،
كما اختبر كيم مؤخرًا صواريخ أطلقت
من القطارات
التي يمكن أن تخرج من مخبأ نفق
في أي لحظة  كيم جونغ أون
يخبر العالم وتحديداً
الولايات المتحدة أن لديها ترسانة مخيفة
من الصواريخ ، وهذا مجرد
مثال آخر للتخويف الذي
نقلوه إلى مستوى جديد تمامًا ، فهم
يتحسنون بشكل أفضل في هذه
الرسالة المهمة الأخرى
يعتقد المحللون أن كيم يرسل مع الاختبارات الأخيرة
في هذا العرض للقوة
لا تراجع عن الأسلحة النووية ، لذا
فإن الرسالة هي أننا خطرون لكننا
لا نتخلى عن أسلحتنا
النووية والتعامل معها الذي تم
عرضه في هذا الحدث الأخير كان أكثر
من  صواريخ الجنود يؤدون
ركلات فنون الدفاع عن النفس تحلق عالياً ، ويحطمون
الكتل ، يصطدم الجندي برأسه
وجندي عاري الصدر من خلال كتلة  حارب
جميع القادمين جميعًا لإسعاد كيم
وأخته كيم يو-جونغ في العديد من
الأحداث الأخيرة ، ظهر كيم بشكل ملحوظ
أقل نحافة مما كان عليه قبل أشهر ، وهذه
المرة تم تصويره وهو يرتدي
صندلًا مصقولًا ببدلة لقد فقد وزنًا
لم نفعله.  تعرف لماذا
يبدو أنه مصاب بالنقرس ، فهو يعرج فهو
ليس شخصًا سليمًا
،
وإذا كنت طبيب كيم جونغ أون
قبل أن تخبره أن يذهب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية أو
يتوقف عن تناول الحلويات المفضلة لديه ، فمن
المحتمل أن تعتقد أن هذا هو الرجل الذي
قتل عمه وأعدم
العشرات من جنرالاته وأتباعه السياسيين ،
لذا أظن أنه لا يحصل على
نظام صارم للغاية من أطبائه ،
يولي خبراء كوريا الشمالية اهتمامًا وثيقًا
لمظهر كيم الجسدي
لسبب وجيه كما وصفه أحد الخبراء بأنه مخيف  نظرًا لأن
تلك الصواريخ الجديدة المعروضة ليست
شيئًا مقارنة بمدى
رعبها إذا مات كيم فجأة وحدثت الفوضى
داخل ذلك البلد المسلح نوويًا